thank you all for being here and thank
you Christmas for the invitation and as
you might anticipate from the title here
this talk is very much an outlier in
this meeting because it has very little
to do with theory and I warned Christos
about that when he invited me but it's
something that I think is of interest
and relevance to all of us in higher
education in terms of how we can change
the way in which we offer education to a
very large portion of the people in this
world and so hopefully it'll be
interesting to you nonetheless so the
title of this talk is the online
revolution learning without limits and
I'm going to start with the online
revolution and I'm going to end with
learning without limits so the online
revolution that we're seeing today you
know the one that the new york times
Christians in late two thousand twelve
is the year of the MOOC started out in
Stanford University at the beginning of
the fall semester of 2011 in September
of 2011 it was a grand experiment that
Stanford did with three courses one of
which was offered by Peter Norvig who's
sitting right here in the audience who
right in front of me in Stanford took
three classes that are fairly advanced
computer science courses and put them up
for anybody around the world to take for
free and I think initially we were
anticipating an enrollment of a few
thousand people but but in a matter of
weeks each of these courses had an
enrollment of a hundred thousand
students or more so to put the number
hundred thousand in perspective the
largest of these courses as offered as
Stanford as the machine learning course
that had at the time an enrollment of
400 I think is up to 600 by now it's
considered large even by Stanford
standards in Sanford has some pretty
large classes when that course was
opened up to the world it had an
enrollment of a hundred thousand so in
order for Andrew
in my coat my colleague to offer that
thought to teach that number of students
he would have to teach a stanford class
for 250 years now besides that somewhat
striking number i think more fundamental
is the fact that by doing so he would
reach 250 generations of fairly
privileged stanford students as opposed
to the students from every age group
every country in every walk of life that
we're able to get access to this
material by virtue of having it be made
freely available to everyone so these
were the first these three were the
first of what are now called MOOCs
massive open online courses and it
really led us to think about the
opportunity that we had to take a
Stanford quality education and offer to
everyone around the world to take at
what is effectively a zero marginal cost
per student because the cost per student
is closer to zero dollars into one
dollar so how do you execute on
something that has this much potential
we discussed it internally within
Stanford for a number of months and in
January 2012 we decided to spin this out
of Stanford as a separate entity now
called Coursera which you can see this
is a fairly recent screenshot is now
partnering with 70 of the world's best
universities to offer 374 courses too
close to 3.7 million students by now
around in every single country of the
world so let me talk a little bit about
some of these some of these statistics
so first of all let me talk a little bit
about the universities these are the US
universities that are working with us
and you can see some of this country's
finest both public and private
universities all contributing some of
their best courses to teach the world
you can see our first four founding
partners Stanford Princeton Penn
admission
several of the UC campuses unfortunately
not Berkeley Duke Johns Hopkins Caltech
and many others as well as some
specialty schools we have two music
schools in an art school as well so this
started out as a u.s. effort but it's
really not where it ended up we
currently have 24 non-us universities
from some some of the best in the world
all offering content to students
everywhere you can see some of the world
top institutions in Europe in Asia in
Latin America Australia Canada we are
fortunate enough by virtue of these
amazing partners to offer courses in no
fewer than six languages English French
Spanish Chinese German and Italian
starting up in the fall and the number
one or two or both ranked institutions
in 14 different countries have decided
to step up and offer free education to
everyone the course you started out in
computer science that's definitely not
where they ended up as you might have
inferred from the range of institutions
courses now spanned pretty much to the
range of disciplines humanities Sciences
engineering business philosophy history
astrobiology music including performance
music art and many others and what we
find maybe some what are surprised
initially we thought the courses that
would be the most popular would be the
ones that offered the direct career
advantage maybe a programming class or
an accounting class but know some of our
most popular classes are history
philosophy music and others let me talk
a little bit about the students and I
can stand here for several hours telling
you students stories about people whose
lives were profoundly impacted by having
access to education that they would
never otherwise have had but I'm just
going to give you three vignettes to
illustrate three different points so the
first of these is an international story
this is roll roll is from Peru he didn't
have much access to computer science
education and proves not very well
developed there but he took a number of
our computer science courses use that as
the basis first Fulbright application
and is now coming to study as a
Fulbright Scholar in the United States
this one is a little bit closer at the
home these are a group of people from a
very poor part of ohio and people whose
life has not for whom life has not
treated them very well these are mostly
women mostly in their 40s and 50s only
one of them has a college degree all of
them are either in a fixed or low income
they got together under the mentoring if
you will of a woman called sherron
watkins they pick together a class that
they were going to take they picked the
grow to greatness class from the Darden
Business School of the University of
Virginia they took it together and kind
of them enrolled in the class nine of
them completed the class and six of them
passed the final exam of an MBA level
course despite having no college
education one of these women is now
going out on her own to become an
entrepreneur based on the material that
she learned in the class and the last
one is one that for me is actually I've
developed a close personal relationship
with his family sitting on the right
there is Daniel who's a 17 year old boy
who's severely autistic daniel has a
speaking vocabulary of about 150 words
he communicates by typing on an iPad
that was designed for him by his father
by doing so Daniel started out taking
the modern contemporary American poetry
class from the University of
Pennsylvania a challenging class even by
Penn standards was the star students in
the class you can seen with the
instructor sitting there on his left and
just last week Daniel's father sent me a
picture of Daniels wall with five
certificates that Daniel earned by
taking Coursera classes and and told me
how proud Daniel is of his
accomplishment so this is another type
of access that this type of technology
provides to people for whatever reason
of health disability learning disability
are unable to make use of a traditional
on-campus college education and we have
a number of these a large number so with
that I'm going to now switch to talk a
little bit about what these courses are
like from the inside so what is the
student experience in these courses so
the first the first point is that we
didn't want this to be just a bunch of
static course materials as you would
find on iTunes U or in some open
courseware site we want this to be an
act of course that the students felt
some level of commitment to and so the
course is like just like college course
it begins on a given day and every week
there is stuff that the students are
supposed to learn and every week there's
homework that the students are supposed
to do and if and the homework is graded
and if the students don't do their
homework they don't get a grade and if
they don't get a grade they don't pass
the course just like a college course
and you can see the implications of that
simple intervention if you will by the
usage graph that you see here the x axis
is time y axis is load on the site and
you can see that little heart shape
pattern each of these bumps is the day
before the deadline
the day before the deadline everybody
logs in to do their homework which
should remind you of i think experiences
you had teaching at our universities and
then at the end just like in a
university there is a reward a
certificate a credential of some kind
and I'll talk a little bit about that at
the end so let's talk about the three
pillars of the student experience first
of those is the video lectures the the
actual content and one of the nice
things is that when you move away from
the constraints of on campus in class
instruction it really opens the door to
some tremendously creative ways of
teaching that are just hard to do when
teaching in a physical classroom so here
is a couple of examples that I'm going
to talk about top left is the University
of Illinois sustainability class they
wanted to really make sustainability
issues come alive so they shot a lot of
the video on site at different places
where sustainability issues are readily
apparent bottom left is the introduction
to sociology class from Princeton our
very first humanities class it was a
humanitarian sociology class in addition
to the weekly lectures the instructor
Mitch denier you can see him on left had
a weekly google hangout chat a
discussion group with ten students
selected from different countries of the
world there was one from Tibet there was
one from India there was one from Africa
one for georgia the country not the
state and they had a discussion for an
hour on the sociology questions of they
that was also live streamed to all of
the students in the class and also
captured and placed on the site for
students to look at later and the
interesting thing is that sociology of
course is such a contextual topic with
different countries different cultures
have very different perspectives that
Mitch denier says that he learned more
from teaching his class one time in this
format than he did from 12 years of
teaching it at Princeton because when
you when he teaches it at Princeton
every year there is a great in class
discussion but every year it's pretty
much the same discussion because this do
come from very similar backgrounds and
here he had such a wealth of different
perspectives that he now has imported
that to teaching his on-campus class in
a completely different way and then you
know there's other things you can do let
me just talk about the gamification
class down at the bottom right that
character that this is from the Wharton
Business School from the right the
character that you can see right there
in the middle is the instructor teaching
part of the class as a computer game
character to make some of the concepts
come alive so that's one kind of
constraint that you can use that I miss
a slide I think I did mrs. life right
the other constraint that you can break
away from is the fact that the lectures
are not no longer need to span 75 or 50
minute blocks rather the student can
come and watch the lectures in show much
shorter units that are much better
suited to their attention spans you
break the content down into eight or ten
minute blocks that are much more
palatable and also in fact better suited
to the emphasis of granularity of the
content i mean we teach at 50 minute
walks because of the constraints of room
scheduling you have to get the students
in teach them something and get them out
before the next group comes in now
you're no longer have to do that and so
this provides a tremendous flexibility
for the student in learning the content
at their own pace at their own time and
in units that make much more sense for
them now of course the lectures
themselves however are also not passive
things and that's one of the things that
we try to do is in order to keep this
material engaging we needed to build in
a lot of opportunities for interactivity
so one of the ideas that we came up with
is called in-video quizzes and you can
see it right here so this is an example
there is sound but I'm not playing it
this is what one of the lectures model
thinking from University of Michigan
looks like and instructor is talking the
video hits the yellow not and the
student gets asked the question and the
student has the opportunity to answer
the question immediately in this case
they're wrong they have a chance to try
again and so on now this is the kind of
question
as an instructor I might ask in my
on-campus class but at least speaking
for myself when I do that eighty percent
of the students are still scribbling the
last thing I said the ones with their
laptop open by and large they're not
taking notes they're on Facebook and I
see those of you of the laptops in the
back and and then there's the smarty
pants in the front row who blurts out
the answer before that's Christos
exactly uh I was thinking that but i was
thinking i'd be polite but maybe not um
who blurts out the answer before pretty
much anybody else in the audience among
the students has realized that a
question had even been asked and then
I'm truly gratified because Christos
knew the answer to my question and then
the class moves on here every single
student engages with the material and
giving them a much better learning
experience now of course those little
baby questions where that's happened in
the middle of the lecture is not where
the meaningful learning happens the
meaningful learning happens in the
weekly homework that the students have
to do and so that obviously raises the
question of how do you grade the work of
a hundred thousand students if you can't
afford to pay five thousand teaching
assistants and so there's two solutions
that we took for this one is to get the
computer to do the nasty work for you
none of us really likes the grade and so
had the nice thing is that there is no
reasonable range of homeworks that
computers can grade automatically and
fairly effectively so there's multiple
choice of different kinds and you can do
a fair bit with multiple choice if you
think about it there's the short answer
questions that I showed you in the
example video there is pretty in-depth
grading of math expressions the grades
not just on syntactic identity between
two expressions but also on semantic
equivalence so you can do a lot more
with that and then there is the grading
of anything that has a structured form
be it the output of a computer program a
computer model or even an Excel
spreadsheet as long as it has a fixed
structure and you know where to find the
pieces you can grade this and so that
really sets up I think and
a sort of this ability of a student
really practice with the work until they
get it so let's see what that looks like
so this is one of the exercises from the
cs 101 class that one of my colleagues
from stanford Todd and you can see the
students supposed to color correct the
image they're actually programming
javascript in the browser so it's all
done in browser the grading in this they
didn't get it the first time they had a
chance to try again and they got it the
second time now that aspect is actually
one of the most fundamental
contributions of computer based grading
which we put in primarily as a
scalability mechanism only to discover
that the pedagogical advantages are even
larger because what happens when a
student submits a piece of work for a
traditional on-campus exercise usually a
matter of three to four weeks elapsed
between the time of the material is
learned they get the homework submit the
homework and get the graded homework
back if they didn't get it by the time
they know they didn't get it it's far
too late for them to go back and really
relearn the material because the class
has moved on here the feedback is
immediate and that turns the whole
interaction into a computer game
especially for this generation because
they get the feedback and they realize
that they're only that they're not doing
so well so they try again like in the
examples that we show you can see the
impact of that in this fairly typical
graph where the blue bars is the initial
distribution of scores for the first
submission of the assignment and the
green bars is the distribution of scores
for the final submission of the same
assignment then you can see that people
naturally gravitate towards achieving a
perfect or close to perfect score now of
course all of you are sitting there
saying well yeah okay fine if you put a
monkey next to the keyboard you let them
try often enough they're going to get a
perfect score also does that indicate
that there's actual learning going on
and so we did some analytics on using
some machine learning modeling and what
came out of it is that it seems that the
answer is yes that is if you look at
students who performed comparably in say
the initial submission of problem set 1
and you look at the ones who did
mastery-based learning versus the ones
who didn't the ones who did
mastery-based learning perform better
also on the initial submission of
problem set 2 which means that they're
actually learning something that
to perform better on future is down the
line not just get a higher score on the
one that they're practicing on and so
that I think is a is an indication that
this is actually valuable pedagogically
okay now this of course only takes you
so far because many classes have
assignments that really cannot be graded
effectively by a computer right now
things that don't have a clear right
answer you know things that correspond
to critical thinking or problem-solving
skills so in order to do that we put in
place a peer grading pipeline that
combines ideas from mechanisms that have
been employed in on-campus classes a
fairly small ones 20 or 30 students
combined with ideas from crowdsourcing
and together that constructed a peer
grading pipeline where students get a
grading rubric or criteria that are
designed by the instructor and are
grabbing the work of their peers to
those criteria and you can do a pretty
broad range of assignments with peer
grading so here for example is a peer
grading of an assignment who's where the
task was to critique a scientific paper
this was in the pen genomics class so
this is critical thinking in its purest
form and the students did the critique
and then other students critique their
critique and told them what they which
points they thought were valid which
points they thought they had missed and
so on and so forth now you might ask
whether peer grading is actually
effective that is our students were not
necessarily skilled in the material
themselves capable of grading the work
of their peers and the answer is
sometimes it really depends on the
quality of the grading rubric if the
instructor puts careful thought into
making sure that the criteria are well
defined then you actually get some
pretty solid results so this is for
example from the Princeton sociology
class that I mentioned earlier the
instructor and his TAS graded 1200 final
exams each
three essay questions and what and they
compared the grades from the tas to the
grades from the peer grading process and
the x-axis is a PA grade the y-axis is
the pier grade and you can see a very
strong correlation that i would argue is
probably as good as you would expect for
to TAS grading the same piece of work
now of course if you have a really bad
grading rubric then you don't get these
results but this shows that you can get
very high quality results from this now
there's two nice things about peer
grading that again we weren't
necessarily expecting going in the first
is that also it is not purely a
scalability mechanism but also a
pedagogical tool because when you think
about a student doing the grading this
is an assignment that they had just
finished struggling with themselves and
so they thought about they do it this
way they could do it that way they
picked a particular path and all of a
sudden they see that there's five
different ways of getting to the same
goal and seeing that the same solution
can be solved in different ways is
really in many ways a first step towards
teaching creativity the other aspect of
this is that you can do a lot of types
of problems in peer grading that we
weren't anticipating going in so here is
the semester long project in a Wharton
Business School design class the
students started out with a problem
specification a concept as a prototype
and finally an artifact and at every
single step of the way they got grades
from and feedback from five of their
peers which means that by the time the
course ended they had bought 140 pieces
of feedback which really helped them
refine their designs and you can see
here some of the 33 of the many final
projects that were submitted in this
course and see that the students
actually ended up doing some pretty
remarkable things in this online class
in a project that you in a tight in the
project class which many people would
have said going in you can't do it a
scale like this and this is by the way
how we great for example our performance
music classes we have a an improv jazz
class being taught by a seven-time
Grammy Award winner from the Berklee
School of Music and their grading improv
jazz pieces using peer grading
the last pillar of the student
experience is the community because the
one one of the very few things that you
really just can't scale is the ability
of an instructor to interact in
meaningful ways with students in the
class because the instructor time
doesn't really extend that far and we
know even it for us as an on-campus
instructor it's difficult to provide
meaningful feedback to more than 100
students so what we've done here is
replaced the hub and spoke model with a
peer-to-peer model where students are
effectively serving as teachers for
other students so students are posing
questions on the discussion forum and
other students are answering those
questions and in many cases they're
answering those questions better then an
instructor would both because they have
more time but also because they have
just finished struggling with that same
problem themselves and so they might
have a deeper insight into what's
confusing about it and therefore provide
a more useful answer and we're told by
many of our students that this in fact
is a more collaborative and sharing
environment than any on-campus courses
because of the sense of community that
gets built up around the course
materials and then of course students
just you know told us by with their feet
that they really also value face-to-face
interaction so without any kind of
prompting they organically created
little communities of people who meet
once a week to talk about the course
materials they needed coffee shops
people's work places or people's homes
and they do their homework together and
talk about the course materials and
there's now well over 2500 communities
of people doing work around these
courses in different cities around the
world
so having finished the course I thought
I mentioned to you that there is some
kind of certificate or credential at the
end so let me talk a little bit about
that this is credentials Oh point one
this is what Stanford University let us
provide in the fall of two thousand in
the fall classes 2011 it's a statement
of accomplishment a letter from the
instructor to the student signed by the
instructor the only place where the
instructors affiliation is mentioned is
it sorry where the institution is
mentioned is in the instructors
affiliation and in fact in the
boilerplate at the bottom that says this
is not a stanford class it doesn't even
resemble a stanford class it doesn't
confer stanford credit and we don't even
know who the student is so despite that
some of vacuous credential students were
actually making use of this for all
sorts of purposes to get in line for an
interview for a job and we know many
students who got jobs based on this
credential but even in some places the
university's habitually gave students
college credits for completing Coursera
classes university of helsinki just made
it a policy other universities did it's
a little bit more on the slide but it
happened the fair bit now however wanted
to do a little bit more than that
specifically get rid of some of that
legal boilerplate and so in January of
2013 so just a few months ago we
launched what we call the signature
track the signature track is a way to
get students to map their
accomplishments to the real world
identity and so what happens is that
when a student decides elect to join a
signature track and it's entirely
optional they join they submit a
government-issued picture ID that that
is then compared to their webcam photo
so we know who they are and then they
also create a biometric profile which in
this case uses keystroke biometrics it
turns out that if crystals and I type
the same phrase it's going to look very
very different in terms of the rhythm
and I can't forge christos a signature
and he can't forge mine even if I try
and help him he can't type like
and so you can now identify students
every time they log into the platform
and confirm that they are in fact
participating in their own learning and
that allows us at the end to give them
what we call a verified certificate that
actually has the university brand on it
and doesn't have all that legal
boilerplate about how we don't know who
the student is now here is one nice
aspect of this that that turns out to be
the case people talk a lot about the
lack of retention in MOOCs it's one of
perhaps the most common criticism
against this against this model now I
think the people who criticize MOOCs for
lack of retention haven't stopped to
think about what a MOOC really is and
what the student population looks like
the vast majority of the students who
enroll in a MOOC have no intent to
complete it they have no intent of
submitting even a single piece of
homework and so sure enough they in fact
they don't complete the course many of
them are treating this like a library
book they login they watch a few
lectures for maybe three or four weeks
at they figure they got something out of
it and then they stop and in the same
way that if you return a book to the
library before you finish reading every
last page of it it's not a failure of
the book it's also not a failure of the
course if you see if a student who
doesn't intend to complete doesn't
complete however when you look at things
like the signature track the question is
in this case students are committing
effectively to completing a class are
they completing the class and so you can
see these are some of the results
whereas the overall completion rate in a
typical MOOC is about 8% the overall
completion rate for students and
signature track is about 75% furthermore
if you look at students win an entry
survey declare that they're highly
committed to completing the class 85 of
those eighty-five percent of those
eighty-four percent of those students
complete the class students sign up for
signature track it's about ninety-five
percent so which actually I guess shows
that if you have some skin in the game
it actually improves your retention
which may be not surprising in
retrospect
okay so that's the signature track and
one thing that about the signature track
is it does cost money easy there is a
human in the loop the human has to
create the you know look at the webcam
photo and song it's not hugely expensive
it costs about fifty dollars it's
entirely optional you can still take the
class and get your statement of
accomplishment without signing up for
this but because we realized that
there's a lot of students out there for
whom fifty dollars is actually a lot of
money maybe not so much in the United
States but in other parts of the world
we put in place from the very beginning
of this program what we call a financial
aid program which is basically a waiver
of the fee for this for this program and
we have given well over a thousand of
these financial aid Awards if you will
to people all around the world and
here's just a few of the examples
there's over a thousand of it i'm not
going to list all of them but let me
just mention a couple there is a
professional in bangladesh who realizes
that half the students in his country
don't have electricity and is taking the
energy class to see how to fix that and
then there is a student in Chile who
wants to apply for PhD programs in the
US or Europe to study Huntington's
disease for family reasons and and so
she's taking the neurons synapses and
brains classroom at your university so
that's the end of the student experience
peace and the last piece of this talk
talks about how we believe this could
improve learning outcomes and we believe
that improvement can be gained in two
very different ways the first is just in
the online format itself and the second
is in face-to-face teaching so in the
online format the first is just the
amazing ability to collect data about
student behavior and student performance
because every component of the platform
is instrumented and we know exactly what
the student is doing when they drop off
watching videos when they rewind to
watch something again looking at a forum
post posting a forum post submitting a
quiz and so on and that gives us
basically a big date of view of human
learning and the opportunity to turn
learning from an anecdotal science to a
data science a transformation that has
revolutionized fields as diverse as
astronomy biology medicine and many
others so how do you use big data in
understanding human learning first of
all you can use it in the context of a
particular course there's one little
vignette this is a distribution of wrong
student answers in one of Andrews
machine learning exercises the answers
happen to be pairs of numbers so you can
graph them on a grid the little crosses
are one-off wrong answers were just a
single just a single student made that
mistake but for example that big cross
at the top left is where 2,000 students
made the exact same wrong answer in this
infinite space now if two students in a
class of 100 make the same mistake
you've never noticed but when it's 2,000
it kind of jumps out and so and rune is
TAS went in understood the basis for the
misconception it turns out the students
were inverting two lines of an algorithm
and now every student whose answer falls
into that bucket doesn't just get a
sorry you're wrong message they get a
sorry you're wrong and you might want to
think about this thereby providing a
much more rapid path to correcting their
learning so that's one place that you
can get improvements the other is by
getting insight into high level pedagogy
that is not necessarily in the context
of a particular class so one question
for example that often gets asked is
should we or should we not show the
instructors face in the video Sal Khan
for example from the Khan Academy is
fairly insistent that showing his face
in the video would just distract the
students other researchers suggest that
it actually is beneficial you know it's
hard to say when you have a small sample
size but here we don't have a small
sample size we have a huge sample size
so we can do what's called in Silicon
Valley jargon a be testing maybe testing
whether you've heard the phrase or not
is something you have undoubtedly
participated in because every time you
log into Google Facebook or any other
large website there is about a five
percent chance that you are in the B
group which is getting a different user
experience in the a group and then the
website is tracking whatever metrics
they care about be
click through rates or anything else and
they are then measuring which group gets
the better outcomes and if the B group
does better than the a group the entire
site flips over in a matter of days
which is what allows these sites the
continuous iterative improvement to the
user experience we've never been able to
do that in pedagogy but now we can so
here is one example of an a/b test in
dan mcpharlin stanford class on
organizational analysis and we tried out
whether the instructors face is good or
not good the a group added the big group
didn't and you're all probably waiting
for me to tell you which group did
better but I won't and the reason i
won't is not because i'm being secretive
is because the students in the B group
we're so pissed off that they didn't see
the instructors face that they
complained on the forums bitterly and
they had to stop the experiments in the
middle and so we don't know if the
students would have done better with the
instructors face then without but we
know the seasons wanted it now this of
course is just one example of a be
testing we've now sort of rolled out a
framework for a/b testing that's sort of
much more reliable and robust than just
a single experiment and we're now
running a/b testing all sorts of
different things that can help us get
better pedagogy ok now the data
analytics and the ability to personalize
the student experience is actually I
think a key
a key aspect in solving what is a
thirty-year-old problem in improving
learning outcomes so there is a very
famous paper called the two sigma
problem by renowned educational
researcher benjamin bloom almost 30
years ago in that paper bloom studied
the achievement score distribution for
three populations the first is the
population of students who learned in a
traditional lecture class not a very
large let's remind you about 35 to 40
people the second population is people
who still learned in a lecture but in a
mastery learning format which means they
weren't allowed to move to the second
topic before demonstrating competence in
the first and the third is the
population of students who are fortunate
enough to have an individual human tutor
and you can see that each of these
interventions gives a full standard
deviation or Sigma improvement in
performance relative to the previous one
so bloom in order to illustrate what a
two segments improvement in performance
is points out that if we pick the
midpoint of the lecture based population
as a performance threshold this is what
the average student gets so half the
students are above that and half the
students are below if we use that same
threshold for the green population the
the individual tutoring ninety-eight
percent of the students are going to be
above that threshold or in a kind of
Lake Wobegon kind of way above average
so that of course is the motivation for
the title of blooms paper the two sigma
problem because bloom points out that as
a society we can't afford to provide an
individual tutor to every student but
maybe we can now provide them with a
tablet or at least the smartphone and so
the question is now can we use
technology to move us from the blue
curve to the red curve and ultimately to
the green curve so the question is I
mean for the red curve I think the
answer is a pretty straightforward yes
computers are actually really good at
mastery because they don't mind showing
you the same video five times
they don't even get judgmental if you
don't get it after the third time and so
the I think the red curve is easily done
the green curve is obviously a little
bit more challenging how do you create
how to use a combination of big data and
analytics to really give the kind of
personalization that allows the student
to get closer to the green group and
that's I think a really exciting
research question the last place where I
think we can get big improvements in
performance is in our own college
classes so this is one of my favorite
quotes by 19th century educator Edwin
slauson who said that college is a place
for a professor's lecture notes go
straight to the students lecture notes
without passing through the brains of
either now maybe not the most flattering
view of the college experience but when
you think about this maybe not
unjustified and so the question is can
we now do something that looks more like
this where students come and into the
material having learned a lot of the
basic content and the basic skills with
the ability to achieve mastery to study
at their own pace to practice and
practice again and then they come into
class to learn those skills that a
computer really can't teach effectively
creative thinking problem-solving debate
explanation the kinds of things that
really require interaction with a human
which currently in large lecture halls
they just don't get so really you get I
think the best of both worlds by leaving
computers to do the teaching that
they're good at and letting faculty do
the kind of teaching that only they can
do so in fact this gives rise to I think
one of the interest one a very
interesting insight that one of our
instructors Christian Turkish from
Wharton he's an operations management
instructor who taught an operations
management class on Coursera and his
last lecture which you can find on
youtube it has a lot of cool insights is
a case study of MOOCs
and Christian says that instruction is a
trade-off along a Pareto optimal
frontier this is the most theoretical
slide in my talk the students tray I
mean you can trade off instruct faculty
productivity the number of students
covered per hour of work with student
learning outcomes traditional
instruction like a large lecture it's
pretty efficient in faculty productivity
because you cover 300 students in one
lecture but learning outcomes are not
that great personalized instruction like
like you know office hours for example
very low productivity great learning
outcomes Christian argues that MOOCs
give us a whole new frontier which give
which provides completely different set
of trade-offs and you can use that
trade-off in different ways for
different student populations so for
example if you want to offer a MOOC to
people in Africa and Bangladesh you
would never have access to education you
can basically keep student learning
outcomes about the same as they would be
in a large lecture class but reduce the
cost per student what is effectively the
zero marginal cost per student that I
started out with or if you want to give
a better education to the students at
your own academic institution then you
can keep faculty load the same but give
them much more of an opportunity to
teach active learning and creative
thinking skills and therefore improve
learning outcomes and obviously these
are just two points on this trade-off
that people can engage with now I'm
going to skip past this um and so I'm
just going to end this is if I had one
more song
I'm just going to end with the last two
slides that talk a little bit about the
breakdown of the student population and
what implications we think it has for
offering people education so currently
about eighty percent of our students
actually have college degrees for about
half of those have advanced degrees and
partly it's because until very recently
we haven't had a mechanism for offering
students credit for the courses that
they're taking and so if you can't give
somebody credit it's kind of the
opportunity cost for them to take a
non-credit bearing class if their degree
seeking is quite high so many of them
don't but at the same time the other
reason why we have such a large fraction
of students who are not for lifelong
learners is because if you think about
it your formal college education ends
about what ten years and you into your
adult life and after that for most of us
maybe not those of you in this room but
for most people the opportunities that
they have to learn new stuff are
actually quite limited they can read a
book watch a PBS documentary find a
babysitter three times a week and go to
a community college class I mean the
opportunities are not great and this
provides people with an opportunity to
learn something really exciting and you
anytime they want and really become
lifelong learners the second break down
of our population is geographic only
about a third of our students are in the
United States about 28 / Center in
Europe forty percent are in what the
State Department defines as the
developing world now these for most of
the countries in the developing world
that are represented in this chart there
really isn't for most people any other
opportunity to get a high quality
education because even if you ignore the
issue of quality there's just are not
enough educational institutions that
many of these countries to offer
education for the many people who need
it in India for example they did a study
a number of years ago and showed that in
order to increase the post-secondary
completion rate from its current level
of thirteen percent to the thirty
percent they
need to get to a 21st century economy
you would need to build 1,500 new
academic institutions 1500 and aside
from the question of where you would be
able to raise the funds and the ability
to build 1500 institutions they don't
have instructors right now to staff the
institutions that they already have so
where would you find instructors to
staff these new institutions so this is
in many ways the I think the only avenue
that you would have to bring education
to the many people in those countries
that needed within this coming
generation as opposed to a generation or
two from now and so I think this is an
opportunity for all of us to take
education and turn it from a privilege
of the few to a basic human right so I'm
just going to end this with one final
anecdote in September of 2012 I attended
the launch of the education first
initiative in the united nations whose
goal it is by the millennium development
goal to bring education to everyone
around the world who wants one and they
were talking about how when you travel
in Africa in even in such places as
refugee camps in the Congo that have you
know where people are living on a cup of
food a day in grass huts and you ask
them what do they want most of them
don't say they want more food or that
they want better shelter they say they
want a better education for their
children because they know that giving
their children education is the only way
to break them out of the cycle of
poverty thank you very much
which is what government by that's a
long walk and teach me very weak
who is going to pay for the preparation
of courses and pay for around why should
you have to remember dear world city the
state pays for less than ten percent of
the budget of Berkeley so things are not
in a good
and we're not going to give away our
equity to improve so the financial
bubble is one that we're currently
working on and there's a couple you know
there's one that's already started to
provide what i consider to be promising
revenue so in the fall in the 1st
quarter of 2013 this verified credential
the fifty-dollar one that i mentioned
earlier running on a handful of classes
for only a couple of months because we
only launched it at the end of january
brought in two hundred and twenty
thousand dollars over five classes right
now we're way past that as we're nearing
the end of the 2nd quarter of 2013 and
still running on a relatively small
fraction of our classes and with an
evergreen increasing student base we are
actually quite I mean we've done some
modeling here and we're actually
somewhat optimistic that this can
provide a reasonable revenue stream to
sustain this effort but sorry can I just
the cost
so the cost of creating these courses is
about say on average thirty to fifty
thousand dollars so it's not a
insignificant amount but it's not huge
and a fee and that they can be reused
again and again with relatively little
modification and so if you're bringing
in a revenue of you know ten to twenty
thousand dollars just to the institution
per class over over a year it actually
has repaid its cost so
nah not that much actually because it's
mostly running but we can maybe talk
about the financial models in more
detail offline but let's put it this way
our investors are confident that this is
going to be fine so
or K through 12 education this would
seem to be buried
so um so people keep asking us that
because as because they correctly point
out that the problems in education often
start a lot sooner than higher education
and that you really need to make an
impact on younger age groups and so
there we have a two-fold answer to that
the first is that we're already starting
to see us over content in high schools
that's that's happening in many of our
upcoming entry level courses intro
physics chemistry programming math and
so on are being used quite commonly by
high school students we don't actually
think this is the right user experience
to teach a seven-year-old how to read or
a five-year-old how to sit still and pay
attention and so in order to help with
that effort we announced about a month
ago a an initiative to teach teachers so
we're not teaching direct to students
but we're providing free teacher
professional development content from a
whole range of institutions including
ones like the British Commonwealth Fund
that are specifically aiming for
teachers at in the developing world so
that they can teach our children better
and part of the millennium development
goals that I mentioned are actually two
to Train two million new teachers by
2015 and so we're hoping that that can
help with that
the online discussion in class
discussions not quality breath the
breath yeah I'm wondering how he'll be
such a discussion structured I mean you
can't review it see every question I
would soon however they so the question
is how does the house an online
discussion structured this was actually
at the video chat so was synchronous and
it was a relatively small group of
students I think eight or nine I forget
the exact number so they you would
actually kind of like a live discussion
except via google hangout we have a lot
of instructors who login religiously
every couple days and engage with the
students in the asynchronous discussion
via the discussion forums and they find
that to be incredibly inspiring and
fought provoking
one of the things that we've put in is a
design of a discussion forum that's
scale so students vote up no you know
it's actually it's a voting scheme so
it's not a random sampling it's a biased
sample so students vote the best
questions up and so the instructor when
he or she logs in gets to see that these
are the 10 questions that the most
students thought were we're interesting
and so they answer those questions and
that gives rise to I think a very high
quality discussion
thank you
scaling skill
curated to crowdsourcing
perhaps rather nationalisms
okay so the question is can we
crowdsource courses that is can you have
multiple instructors contributing to the
construction of a course and I guess my
answer is it's not a technical that's
not a technological question it's a it's
a pedagogical question certainly we have
courses that are authored by multiple
people we have I think the largest we've
had a seven co instructors teaching
together and we're very supportive of
that I think I'm less a fan of the
grounds up let people add stuff and
create something together because you
end up then with something that looks
like Wikipedia which means it's sort of
meanders and sort of goals in different
directions sorry but we've is very
useful mind you don't want to upset
anybody but um but it doesn't it's not
open sourcing I think he's going to be
very a lot so you know with that also
crowdsourcing maybe make babies
problematic beginning and choosing so
yeah and that's up to the instructor I
mean if you're an instructor who wants
to get feedback from people and you
basically play the role of curating your
content so that you end up with
something that you consider to be
coherent that's great I'm a little leery
of just letting people contribute to a
single hole and expecting that to give
rise to a coherent course experience
that that's just my own perspective but
you know maybe you're wrong that's a
really good question I can tell you who
doesn't own it we don't own it the
dilemma is whether the University all
that or the instructor owns it or
whether it's a joint ownership different
universities think drastically different
policies on this and I can tell you
about some of the models that I've heard
that it's outside my jurisdiction we do
not lay claim to any of the IP
universities involved a lot more
courses are being offered is there I
worried that moreover
you know so the question for those of
you in the back is are we worried that
now there's more universities and more
courses being offered of having
extensive overlap so we have 374 courses
right now it's a lot by symmetric a
typical university has between four and
six thousand courses so I think when if
you took your average course catalog and
you threw a dart added chances are you
would hit a class that we don't offer
and so I'm not super worried about
overlap right now and furthermore I
think that if you had three four
versions of calculus which by the way we
already do I think that would only be to
the betterment because it would give
people choices do we need 500 versions
of calculus probably not but I think
having five or ten is actually good and
we're nowhere close to that yet javi
what
Oh
huh
every professor of the top
so I don't think that this is a
substitute for for having a professor
and I read a quote somewhere recently
that where somebody said if you can
actually be replaced by a computer than
maybe you should be so I think that what
professors offer is
huh
I think what you get at a place like
Princeton and Stanford is really unique
and the ability to interact in a very
one-to-one fashion with somebody who is
the leading scholar in their discipline
is a unique opportunity and in the same
way that you know we can now buy a song
on iTunes for 99 cents and yet my
daughters are at me all the time to take
them to the Taylor Swift concert that's
happening in Sacramento of all places in
july or august i mean people still value
that that much more intimate experience
I don't think universities are going
away what I think is going to happen is
that universities are going to have to
redefine their value proposition to be
about something other than content
because content high quality content is
about to become free and ubiquitous and
so the question is what do you provide
to your students that transcends that
and I think that all of us have an
opportunity at all levels of the
academic ashalon is to have a much more
significant impact on our students
whether it's at a place like Princeton
or Stanford where it's the ability to
interact with a leading researcher or in
a community college where you have kids
coming in who didn't learn the study
skills they should have learned in high
school and this is a place for maybe
they have a chance to learn for the
first time so I think there's
opportunities here he's
yes
oh yeah
great
the short answer is yes we don't we
don't have the capability right now to
deal with individual instructors so
we're doing it by institutional
partnerships oh there's one down here
Christo's also so so which one do you
want first okay do you do you measure
other than well I guess our fact that
this
rooms do you measure the
the vibration
let that change the
oh my gosh
in the classroom setting
so you know I think that so sorry yes so
the question is do we think that this is
missing the human element that you would
have by sitting in a classroom together
and seeing faces and I have two answers
to that the first is that today's
generation is actually in many ways
preferring to get their interaction via
digital media now you you know you and I
are from a different generation but my
kids would happily sit in a room net in
two different rooms chatting each other
than as they would to be I know it's
crazy but that's what they seem to like
so I think that there is a generational
aspect of this and today's generation is
actually much more accepting of the kind
of interaction you get by a digital
media the second piece of it is that
this is not by any means of prohibition
to come together and learn so when I
talked about the Ohio experiment these
were 10 people who got together once a
week facilitated by this woman to
sherron watkins to learn the material
together in augmenting what they learned
in the online format and so I think
really what you want is the best of both
worlds as opposed to just want or just
the other
instamatic is
and they use the defectors
I'm sorry I didn't hear the last part so
I mean so the platform is actually
instrumented every last inch of it so we
know exactly what the students are doing
and at every moment that they're logged
into the platform I think that you know
there's tremendous opportunities to use
that to get insights into into human
learning that we've only started to
scratch the surface of and I've
mentioned a couple of the results we've
done a few other studies butter
analytics team is two and a half people
they're busy building out dashboards and
collecting data and doing the basic
analytics but fortunately we share all
of our data back with the universities
that provided the courses and so it's
each one of our many partner
universities that have already offered
courses there's teams of people starting
to look at the dana and see what they
learn about that from that data about
the efficacy of peer grading mastery
learning which is a study that we did as
well as a whole variety of other
questions that one can now finally start
the answer
you